[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning a
recent study shows debt from medical
care has skyrocketed in the united
states more than half of all the bills
in collection right now are medical
bills that means debt collectors have
gotten involved our consumer
investigative correspondent anna werner
has been looking into this and joins us
now anna what have you learned so far
well dana a lot actually think because
you have a job you won't wind up in
bankruptcy or facing a lifetime of
medical debt payments you might as the
stories of two americans illustrate so
well
florida resident chad kish's medical
debt story began with severe pain from
herniated discs in his neck last year i
really couldn't get out of bed for more
than a few minutes
doctors told the 39 year old who runs
his own small pest control business that
he would need surgery so he checked to
make sure his insurance would cover it
then went ahead the pain was
excruciating that was probably the most
pain i've ever
been through but afterwards he got stuck
with a bill for a facility charge he
says the insurance company refused to
pay
145 thousand dollars he says the
hospital then demanded payments of
15-hundred dollars a month i
told him that can't happen
can we go with something lower
and they said no so i just stopped
answering their calls when he couldn't
pay the hospital sued him is this one of
those things that hit you in the gut and
you're like oh boy
you know now what do i do
you know and why is it happening to me
he's not alone a new jam of study finds
medical bills are the largest source of
american debt with a record 140 billion
dollars in collections owed last year
nearly twice the previous estimate it's
all about the medical bills yeah it's
sort of a uniquely american phenomenon
stanford professor neil mahoney the lead
author says bills are often higher for
people living in a dozen states that
chose not to expand eligibility for
medicaid under the affordable care act
the fact that the health care system
which is supposed to
heal people is creating half of debt and
collections in the united states
is
something that i i think is
quite distressing one of those states is
wisconsin where 38 year old alyssa gummo
lives i felt like a criminal like i was
doing something wrong
last october a man showed up at her
front door in kenosha with a court
summit she was being sued for unpaid
medical bills did you ever think that
you would be in the financial situation
you're in because of medical bills never
it just makes me feel like a failure
this is when they were suing you yes and
it's the second time back in 2017 a 50
000 bill for hip surgery forced her into
bankruptcy despite having a full-time
job
you know middle-class americans
we get the short end of the stick
it's it's not fair
this time the single mom has a job that
pays more but not enough to pay new
bills not covered by her high deductible
insurance plan this is lisa from
americalash i'm a debt collector debt
collectors call day and night she's now
on a payment plan but says the extra 193
dollar a month bill often leaves her
choosing between prescriptions and
groceries i sit at my computer and i try
and
you know balance my bills and
i just
just want to give up back in florida
kish says he was able to negotiate his
bill down with a self-paid discount but
is still on the hook for roughly 50 000
and now he'll be paying 125 dollars a
month until it's gone which will take
some 33 years very very frustrating and
you know i
don't think i should be paying the
amount that i have to pay
well keep in mind that study only looked
at debt that was already in collections
so it's not the entire picture here data
from the pandemic isn't reflected yet
and mahoney says he expects that to be
even worse now if you have a story about
you and your medical bills to tell us
email us at healthcosts
cbsnews.com tony unfortunately anna i
think a lot of americans have similar
stories and you'll be hearing from them
thank you very much